[Musique]
une vague rose déferlent sur le stade
olympique de montréal le 16 août 1984 à
l'invitation de diane dufresne
la diva insisté pour que ses fans soient
vêtus de rose
ils sont 55 minutes à montréal son gain
quand on dit rose à moriat l'aise ses
roses de la tête aux pieds
[Musique]
le jour est historique c'est la première
fois qu'une artiste québécois se produit
en solo au stade olympique de montréal
je regarde c'est quand je suis arrivé
sur scène c'est quand j'ai vu que le
stade était rose les cas vous arrivez au
stade et qui devient rose
c'était très impressionnant c'est une
des plus belles choses que j'ai vu de ma
carrière
le choix de la couleur rose n'est pas
anodin le rose à l'époque là c'est
vraiment kaboul vote mais pas ça à moins
d'avoir l'oralair à puce et fils est là
le stade est en rose ce sans doute une
des premières manifestations de la
présence gaie à montréal
la diversité le laverait elle est l
offre
le spectacle est financé par le
gouvernement du québec et diane dufresne
a insisté pour que les billets coûtent
10 $ et que certains soient offerts aux
plus démunis en 84 le taux chômage les 2
13% l'économie votre très très mal c'est
glauque
c'est guéri et ce spectacle qui pour
marquer le 450e de l'arrivée de jacques
cartier ici il veut donner aux gens un
espoir
la conception du spectacle a nécessité
neuf mois de travail
la chanteuse collabore avec la metteuse
en scène mouffe est avec les meilleurs
techniciens et je lui prépare en slow
motion léger des champions à côté de moi
je me disais ce qu'il faut faire il faut
manger ce qu'il faut penser maintenant
enfants j'ai même le lycée avait tout
[Musique]
le dispositif scénique est époustouflant
une réplique du parc belmont a même été
construite dans le stade le stade
olympique ça va toujours rester le stade
olympique
c'est pas c'est pas une place pour faire
un concert c'est plutôt une place pour
faire des happenings et ce qui fait que
ça marche et ben c'est diane tout
simplement ça et malgré tous les défis
techniques qu'on a eu
mais au lendemain du concert les
critiques sont assassin's il face au
tollé
diane dufresne petit le québec il part
s'installer en france elle est reçue
écoute avec un final une brique une
pépine 14 bâton je relisais les
critiques de l'époque c'était c'était
mesquin mais la captation vidéo du
spectacle contribuer à lui donner une
deuxième vie au québec et en france et
permet aux téléspectateurs de re
découvrir la prestation haute en
couleurs de la star
[Musique]
magie rose s'est imposé comme un des
concerts mythiques des années 80 diane
dufresne reste à ce jour la seule
artiste québécoise à s'être produit en
solo au stade de l'été ici n'a dit
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal